[Musik]
die hochzeitsplanerin und das künftige
brautpaar in der hochzeitssuite kurz
löst sich die anspannung der letzten
wochen
[Musik]
das paar will wie viele in deutschland
im schloss feiern im großen stil
alles muss perfekt sein 12.000 euro
wollen sie für den großen tag ausgeben
weil man letztlich einmal im leben nur
heiraten sollte das wird ja schon wird
auch so sein ja und da sagen wir uns
geben wir ein bisschen mehr aus so etwas
besonderes sein wir wollen diesen tag
uns immer wieder daran zurückerinnern
und deswegen haben wir gesagt okay das
ist es wert ein bisschen mehr auszugeben
und es soll etwas unvergleichbares
werden es wird ein feuerwerk geben es
wird golf gespielt und eine band darf
auch nicht fehlen
das muss immer verrückter werden wie zum
beispiel dass man schaut wenn man
irgendwo unterwegs ist dass man den tag
so gestaltet dass man immer abwechslung
drin hat ob dann kommen die kellner
kommt da die gäste bespaßt ob den
karikaturisten haben der dann
karikaturen von den gästen gestaltet ob
wir irgendwo bild mit einem boot und
wasserskifahren und das hat man letztes
jahr dass die gäste wasserski fahren
konnten
also all die dinge die zum zum spaß
bringende beitrag beim floristen zeigt
sich der einfluss der sozialen medien
wie facebook oder instagram sie bieten
inspiration setzen die paare aber auch
unter druck
noch schöner noch besser als andere zu
sein
aufgrund der heute im dienst muss man
ganz klar sagen kriegen sie selbst
vorgelebt nah und man bilder einfach ein
stück weit mithalten
im internationalen vergleich rangiert
deutschland bei den ausgaben für
professionell geplante hochzeiten eher
im mittelfeld
hierzulande liegen sie im schnitt bei
15.000 euro zu den spitzenreitern zählen
die usa mit 30.000 euro und china dort
werden in den großstädten locker 42.000
euro hingeblättert bei den russischen
hochzeiten ist so dass es die ganze zeit
in moderation gibt die gäste werden den
ganzen tag der spaß ist fließt viel
alkohol des brautpaares grundsätzlich
alleine am tisch
das ganz anders
bei uns und und die türkischen
hochzeiten sind oft sehr sehr groß da
wird auf essen überhaupt gar keinen wert
gelegt sondern es fängt sehr sehr spät
an noch es wird spät begonnen es sind
meistens turnhallen die die da genutzt
werden
fast jeder neue lebensabschnitt wird zum
event sogar die scheidung was man im
junge hochzeitspaar nicht wünschen will
[Musik]